what's going on reject nation I'm Greg
Alba this is Tara Ericsson you sit
around a channel before follow her the
terror Ericsson channel on YouTube
hashtag this idiot
what dudududududududu - yeah oh my god
this is so much fun i watch the trailer
for a Jeffrey Dahmer movie right Ellie
what better way to get pumped up and
dance a little bit now we know a ton
about Jeffrey Dahmer a lot I think our
first conversation was about Jeffrey
Dahmer the dawn man the dog I called the
dog much everything the dumb man whoever
the dumb man ah boy dark content on
YouTube you know this is going to
perform well let's do this do it
and hey Schism this well I like her yeah
very nicely Jeffrey Dahmer very nice
when she dated Alan and then she didn't
I remember how much she hated for a day
I realized
[Music]
oh boy
ultimate school
tt been like a graphic novel comic book
balance
another people my god
[Music]
you're not at all anymore like that
sympathetic your turn
she's only me
what about what's on a patient's mind
Jess will often I think you can alert my
leg bones is interesting what's inside I
see things in you that I don't like
about myself what you have friends
anyways that I never could
you just like anybody else not a
slideshow attraction
okay his post on your shelf easy more
normal I now present you Jeffrey Dahmer
in his command performance oh boy
why why performance performance oh good
my husband and school he'll when he just
in the middle of the freaking hallway
needed my mom terrified terrifying
because we know about what the DOM is
going through at that time he's like
stroking little bones and his hands man
dude that's nuts I'm like we could spend
forever talking about what Jeffrey
Dahmer did and all that we'll just stick
to what we see going on in the trailer
right now I feel like films like this
are quite the controversial piece of
material terror Eric darn thing it is
taking a sympathetic portrayal towards
the man who committed these horrible
crimes necrophilia
cannibalism they did some horrible
horrendous things yet this trailer is
done in a way where you're like I feel
kind of sorry for the guy removing and
you know he looks like Jeffrey Dahmer I
just feel like he really does and yeah
they make you feel bad because his mom
was like beating his dad his dad was a
chair yeah and now I wants to just kill
all the men in the world because they
remind him of his dad how you like that
psychological breakdown yet oh whoa ha
Patera dozen or Channel guys check it
out ecology I think it would be
interesting because I'm fascinated by
serial killers might be a weird thing to
admit on the internet but I've always
had a fascination with them I don't know
how people will respond to like a movie
that kind of portrays it in a
sympathetic fashion it looks like it
could be a really good film actually
this I agree there's like Dahmer films
and a lot of films about real-life
serial killers tend to suck this seems
like a very specific story about him it
doesn't somebody's trying to cover isn't
I
our life to look trying to cover a very
specific period he went through during
school and maybe his first few kills
yeah I guess gonna cover the entirety of
everything
no because also he was deemed insane but
then during his trial he was not deemed
that it was deemed saying legally sane
so I'm like which one is it then and you
know what nowhere nation here the entire
trailer where one man hey Shh that's all
we care about think I was watching this
not to be and also the public shot
really well too
yeah that's great as this eerie tone
intention to it that's uh it seems like
a way it's shot is capturing the inside
of his mind the entire time it's one
thing to step inside a fictional serial
killers mine but when you're steppin
into the real one no oh this is why you
don't bully do you see how he was
bullied all kids who are bullied turn
out into everything yeah every single
warning they start carrying around
little bones in her hand rubbing them
being like I hope they don't bully me
today and then they of bullying in and
he's like I need more bones I feel like
when we when we think of Jeffrey Dahmer
we think of everything after he was
already caught because that's when we
have all the footage of him that's when
we have all the interviews of him so I
think it would be fascinating to see the
portrayal of when he was younger and
what did turn him into all of this
because you know everything stems from a
root cause of all this stuff and I'm
interested to see the portrayal of what
the root cause of all is is yes and oh
my gosh and can I just say that he was
probably dropped on his head or hit his
head and I hope that that's in this
movie because it's actually true a high
high high percentage like eighty percent
of people who are Sarah learners I'm not
joking they have been dropped on their
heads they hit their heads and they were
a kid go look it up where'd you get this
stuff go look it up I get my stats from
where people get their stats okay Blanco
you can subscribe to the rail regex
people good that notification Belle
Terre Erickson is Tara Erickson on
YouTube Twitter wait your Twitter
Instagram terrorism my Instagram is at
Tara Erickson my twitter is the terraces
there's only one so you're talking down
to the crowd right now at hashtag this
idiot go check her out people and also
check out our patreon for exclusive
perks and rewards hmm I have one too oh
yeah hi